weg mit winnetou das ist realistisch das
ist der aufreger des tages
viele sind mit ihm groß geworden er
indianerhäuptling winnetou hält der
berühmten karl may bücher hält der karl
may festspiele und der ist auf einmal
weg vom fenster vor wenigen tagen
startete ein neuer film namens der junge
häuptling winnetou darin geht es um den
sohn des altbekannten winnetous der film
läuft soweit so gut doch das buch zum
film das ist schon wieder aus den
regalen verschwunden schuld massive
kritik in den sozialen medien rassismus
und kulturelle aneignung der buchverlag
der zug jetzt die notbremse
wir unterwerfen uns einer radikalen
minderheit das sagt der rechtsanwalt
joachim steinhöfel heute in seiner
kolumne in bild und jetzt sprechen wir
mit e mails mehr zugeschaltet schönen
guten tag herr steinhöfel sie sind vom
ravensburger verlag enttäuscht sagen sie
warum das der verlag gemacht hat halte
ich für ein feiges kapitulieren vor
denunzianten teilweise sind diese leute
anonym
ein zivilisatorisches versagen ein
verlag steht für kultur für presse für
bücher für dichtung und da schreien 200
leute auf twitter oder instagram und
schon kapituliert man das muss man sich
mal vorstellen man geht auf einen
spielplatz der laufen 54 gerungen und
wollen cowboy und indianer spielen und
die fünfjährigen die das wort indianer
benutzen oder spielen wollen sind dann
alles rassisten weil die eltern von dem
anderen kind ihnen das erzählt haben die
armen kinder kann ich nur sagen und
armes deutschland wenn wir verlage haben
den jedes rückgrat fehlt für grundrechte
geradezustehen schauen wir uns mal
gemeinsam die erklärung an der
ravensburger verlag ich eben gesagt hat
das buch von vom markt genommen und auf
instagram wunder denn diese erklärung
veröffentlicht die begründung dafür und
darin schreibt der verlag ihr feedback
hat uns deutlich gezeigt dass wir mit
den winnetou titeln die gefühle anderer
verletzt haben das war nie unsere
absicht und es ist auch nicht mit
unseren ravensburger werden zu
vereinbaren wir entschuldigen uns dafür
ausdrücklich jetzt kann man ja sagen der
verlag will eigentlich alles richtig
machen möchte rücksicht nehmen möchte
dass sich niemand verletzt führt wie
beurteilen sie die rechtfertigung das
ist vollkommen in disco habel besten
gefühle wurden verletzt wer sind diese
ungefähr 200 schreihälse die auf den
sozialen medien sich gemeldet haben von
denen man im großen halle gar nicht weiß
wer das überhaupt war darf ich etwas
sarkastisch ein waren auch irokesen zu
manchen oder apachen dabei oder hat sich
hier irgendeine demokratisch nicht
legitimierte minderheit zum sprecher für
die indianer gemacht und war vor kurzem
noch ein reservat
gefühle zu verletzen kann doch niemals
in einer freien gesellschaft die die
meinungsfreiheit kennt das kriterium
dafür seien um ein buch erscheinen darf
oder nicht wird jetzt morgen auch ein
buch das sich gegen donald trump richtet
um markt genommen weil die gefühle von
donald trump verletzt worden die grenze
zieht das strafrecht und nicht heute als
vogue bezeichnete politisch korrekte
aktivisten
vielleicht hat man den der
geschäftsführung des verlags ja auch
gedroht die nächste nächstes mal die
ration feuer wasser zu kürzen denn davon
muss man einiges getrunken haben bevor
man diese veröffentlichung auf instagram
freigegeben hat
keinerlei verständnis aber wie könnte es
mit dem buch weiter gehen also was
könnte der ravensburger verlag jetzt tun
es wort indianer ersetzen im sinne
lösung das kommt natürlich überhaupt
nicht infrage aber ich habe glaube ich
eine ziemlich gute idee die auch zeigt
wie sehr das auf gegenliebe stößt und
wie nicht warum bringt man das buch
nicht heraus und dann eine zweite
ausgabe politisch korrekte version
2022 vor alles geändert wird und alles
gestrichen wird und indianer und rothaut
und martha fall und potent skalpieren
nicht vorkommt und dann kann man sich
aussuchen was man seinen kindern als
lektüre zumuten will und dann kann man
auch schauen wie viele leute denn dieses
buch kaufen 180 patienten auf twitter
haben sie ja schon mal zusammen in das
vielleicht auch gleich finde zweite
auflage da nicht erreicht
rechtsanwalt joachim steinhöfel
herzlichen dank für dieses gespräch
[Musik]